hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outboard and in this
video I will explain the massive and
absolutely crazy time skip that occurs
at the end of the demon slayer's story a
Time skip that takes us from the taisho
period in which the Story begins all the
way up to modern times we learned what
happens to all of the demon Slayers we
learned about their descendants we learn
about reincarnations and much more in
this video I will be explaining all of
that for you guys right here in one
place and then I will also look at some
hypotheticals like what if our main
characters became the next generation of
hashira what if new major villains
appeared during the time Skip and what
if there is a sequel to Demon Slayer if
you guys enjoy our demonstrator content
then you want us to keep it going just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
that YouTube algorithm and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you've been
watching our video videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications it seems like a small
thing but subscribing is a very real and
totally free way of supporting the
channel directly now a quick shout out
to our partner I taikuji itaikuji is an
online retailer in Japan that makes
anime merch that is normally exclusive
to Japan available to fans all over the
world they have a huge selection of
awesome anime merch straight from Japan
including an entire section on Demon
Slayer they've got the best Demon Slayer
figurines I've ever seen available for
pre-order right now including tanjiro
rengoku tenge nakaza and more check them
out Link in the description and because
we're partnered with them you can now
use coupon code anime Opera 500 for an
instant discount just register on
account for free it's really quick and
you'll be able to use the coupon when
you use the coupon code you are not only
getting awesome merch but directly
supporting this channel so check it out
Link in the description finally this
video will of course contain Demon
Slayer manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in
chapter 204 of the Demon Slayer manga
which is the second last chapter of the
series The Demon's hair core is
disbanded because they have accomplished
their main objective they defeated muzon
and eradicated the demons well not all
demons but more on that later we get to
see tanjiro and the others recovering
from the injuries that they sustained
during the moves on Battle we get to see
a bunch of people visiting our heroes
and checking up on them including uzui
and his wives senjuru and shinjiro
rengoku the swordsmiths GUI and sakonji
and so on we also get some pretty big
hints that the tanjiro X kanao and
inosuke X OWI ships are going to sail
and then the rest of the chapter is
dedicated to honoring the countless
lives lost in the centuries-long
struggle against muzon at the the end we
see tanjiro and nezuko accompanied by
innosken zenitsu returning to the kamado
family home where they honored the
deceased members of The Commodore family
and even though this final scene feels
like it could be the end of the entire
story the final panel of chapter 204
introduces a massive and shocking time
skip a Time skip that takes us all the
way to modern day Tokyo in chapter 205
the last full official chapter of the
demon Sayer manga we get to see modern
Tokyo and we get to meet the modern day
descendants and reincarnations of all of
our favorite Demon Slayer characters we
even got to see a couple of characters
from the taisho period who are still
alive in the modern world so let's break
it all down tanjiro and Kano ended up
together in their modern day descendants
are two boys 16 year old kanatakamado
and 15 year old sumihiko kamado tanjiro
and kanau are the great great
grandparents of Kanata and sumihiko
despite being a boy Kanata Bears a
stunning resemblance to kanal and
sumihiko looks almost exactly like
tanjiro the only differences are that
his hair is a bit shorter and he doesn't
have the birth mark on his forehead the
Sumi in sumihiko is most likely a
reference to sumioshi the ancestor of
tanjiro and nezuko in the past sumihiko
and kanata's grandmother told them
stories about demons but she said that
their great great grandma and
great-great-grandpa worked hard to
defeat them as such there is no longer a
need to be afraid of demons the grandma
who would be the granddaughter of
tanjiro and Kano also said that all the
people who died fighting against demons
were definitely reborn and are now
living new lives with their loved ones
sumihiko seems to have inherited
tanjiro's endless kindness and
compassion because he hopes that even
those who were demons could one day be
forgiven and reborn into the world as
normal happy humans he also wonders what
his great-great-grandparents were like
and he envies those who knew them in
terms of personality sumihiko does have
a lot in common with tanjiru as I said
he seems very kind and compassionate he
is also friendly and cheerful and he is
very athletic and proficient in parkour
that said he seems much more laid back
than tanjiro and he's also more likely
to break the rules he often gets in
trouble for sleeping in late and then
taking some very dangerous shortcuts in
order to make it to school on time
Kanata kamado seems a lot more calm and
composed than sumihiko and he is also
more responsible Kanata is the one who
tries to wake sumihiko up in order to
get him to school on time but that
mission often turns out to be impossible
according to the second demon Sayer fan
book sumihiko and Kanata are able to
perform the hinokami kagura because the
dance was passed on through the
generations of the Commodore family all
the way up to the current generation
they performed the dance once a year at
a a shrine that is maintained by the
ubayashiki family but kanatai and
sumihiko don't seem to realize that this
dance is actually a powerful breathing
style that was used to fight demons
zenitsu and nezuko also ended up
together and their modern day
descendants are 17 year old
yoshitaruagatsuma and his 18 year old
sister Toko agatsuma they also have two
younger sisters who don't appear in the
Final Chapter yoshitero looks almost
exactly like zenitsu back when he had
his normal black hair and the name
yoshiteru is likely another reference to
sumioshi sumihiko has the Sumi part and
yoshitaru has the Yoshi part yoshitaru
actually knows about the history of the
demon Slayers and the defeat of muzan
because his great-grandfather zenitsu
left an account of everything in a book
he wrote called The Legend of zenitsu
and yeah of course he decided to name
his journal the legend of zenitsu
yoshitaru's sister Toko who looks a lot
like nezuko believes that great grandpa
zenitu's Journal is just a fictional
novel and a bunch of Lies but yoshitaru
believes that it's real and just like
sumihiko's Grandma yoshitaru also
believes that all of those who died
fighting the demons will be reborn into
a happier life yoshitaru's personality
is pretty similar to zaritsu he is often
over dramatic when it comes to his
reactions he is very interested in the
ladies just like send it to us and in
general he just has that jittery zenitsu
energy but despite looking a lot like
nezuko yoshitaru's big sister Toko seems
to have a different personality from her
great grandma she is quick to dismiss
all talk of demons and she is quite
aggressive towards her brother she even
physically attacks him while she is in
the process of scolding him over
something inosuke and AWI ended up
together and their descendant is the 28
year old Alba hashibira like his
ancestor inosuke Alba has feminine
facial features and when he first saw
him yoshitaru thought that Alba was a
girl Alba is a botanist who actually
discovered the legendary blue Spider
Lily that muzan had been trying to
locate for his entire life apparently
the blue Spider Lily only blooms during
the day for two or three days a year so
it was extremely difficult to find and
yet after going through all that trouble
of finding and researching this
extremely rare flower someone in the
research team made a mistake and all of
the flowers withered after that the
research program came under intense
criticism and Alba lost his job he met
sumihiko one day when they were both
crying in the same park and the two of
them became friends they like to play
badminton together Alba also has one
little brother but the brother does not
appear in the story
tengiruzui has a descendant by the name
of Tenma uzui Tenma is a 20 year old
gold medalist in gymnastics he is known
for having a flashy attitude and for
doing things like giving the middle
finger to the camera and choking
reporters who tried to follow him around
he also has seven siblings our boy guiyu
has a descendant as well his name is
gichi tomioka and he is an elementary
school student the butterfly estate
girls have descendants and they are just
normal schoolgirls the swordsmith hotaru
haganezuka also has descendants and
there is a maintenance store in modern
Tokyo called haganezuka maintenance
kotetsu kanamori goto and Takeuchi also
have descendants as does murata murata's
descendant is a school principal who
tries to close the school gate before
sumihiko and tojiro can get in but they
still manage to get to class on time by
just hopping over the fence and speaking
of tojuro that is when things get
interesting not all characters that we
see in modern day Tokyo are descendants
of the original characters some of the
characters in chapter 205 who look and
act almost exactly like the characters
we know from the taisho period cannot be
descendants of The Originals because the
original characters never had children
if we accept the words of sumihiko and
kanata's grandmother and yoshitaru's
words as well then we can assume that
those characters are not descendants but
reincarnations of those who died in
battle while fighting muzon and the
demons those who sacrificed their lives
to defeat muzon have been reincarnated
into a happier life in the modern world
and this was foreshadowed multiple times
throughout the course of the series
these reincarnations include muichiro
tokito and his brother yuichiro who have
been reincarnated into the modern world
as twin babies we also have shinobu and
kanae who have been reincarnated as
regular high school girls that yoshitaru
is clearly attracted to gyome has been
reincarnated as a kindergarten teacher
which suits his character and backstory
perfectly best girl mitsuri and iguro
have been reincarnated as a married
couple who operate a diner together the
diner is known for its snake decorations
and massive portion sizes which is a
hint that mitsuri niguros still have the
same personalities as they did in their
former lives mitsurian iguro also have
five children together Kanata says that
he can't show his face at that
restaurant anymore because the last time
they went yoshitaru kept staring at
mitsuri's big chest and iguro ended up
throwing a knife at them because
yoshitaru wouldn't stop staring zenitu
Sensei giguro was also reincarnated but
even in the modern world he is already
an old man and he looks almost exactly
as he did before he also enjoys playing
shogi sabito and makomo have been
reincarnated as elementary school kids
and they are best friends with gyu's
descendant gichi in the extra pages that
were included with the final volume of
the manga it is revealed that yorichi
and his wife and child were also
reincarnated into a happier life but now
let's get back to tojoro and also let's
talk about genya and sanami because
sometimes the line between modern day
descendants can be become a bit blurry
so for example tojoro is confirmed to be
the descendant of senjuro kyojiro
rengoku's younger brother but at the
same time he has an almost identical
personality to kyojro himself and it is
heavily implied that he is indeed The
Reincarnation of kyojiro since kyojiro
also died in battle against the demon it
would only make sense for him to also be
reincarnated and it seems that he was
reincarnated as his brother's descendant
in terms of sanami he has a modern day
descendant who became a police officer
this descendant has a partner who is
like a brother to him and this partner
seems to be The Reincarnation of genya
it appears that these two guys used to
be delinquents and they actually got
into a fight with each other and scarred
each other's faces with knives then they
were arrested together and eventually
they became friends turned their lives
around and became cops finally there are
a couple of characters from the original
story who are still alive in the modern
world yushiro is still alive because he
is a demon and he hasn't aged he has
become a famous artist known for
creating beautiful paintings of a woman
who looks a lot like Tamayo he has
recently gained International Acclaim
but he is a very private individual and
he is rumored to even shoot at reporters
who tried to interview him this makes
sense since the more people learn about
yushiro the more likely they are to
figure out that he doesn't age the cat
chachamaru is also still alive and still
living with yushiro due to the fact that
you should have turned the cat into a
demon before the battle against muzan
finally kiria ubyashiki the son of
kagaya ubayashiki is also still alive
but he is not alive due to some sort of
demonic power he is simply really old
and in fact he is currently the oldest
living person in Japan he is presumably
over 108 years old at this time and he
is still friends with yushiro and those
are all the details that we get about
the time skip in the Final Chapter and
the extra pages there is no doubt in my
mind that the mangakau of Demon Slayer
koyoharu kotoke fully intended to leave
things as is after the Epic defeat of
muzon demons were no longer a threat the
demons are core disbanded and everyone
lived happily ever after that was
certainly the original plan however
after the manga ended in May of 2020
Demon Slayer continued to absolutely
blow up in popularity Mugen train became
the highest grossing Japanese film of
all time and the highest grossing film
of 2020 with over half a billion in
earnings despite the fact that he was
released during a pandemic the Demon
Slayer manga would also go on to become
by far the best-selling manga of 2020.
Demon Slayer sold over 82 million copies
in 2020 alone which was literally 10
times more than the second best-selling
manga Kingdom even in 2021 long long
after the Demon Slayer manga ended demon
Slayers still sold almost 30 million
copies despite ending the year before
Demon Slayer was still the second
best-selling manga after the still
ongoing Jujutsu Kaizen manga which sold
only about a million more copies than
Demon Slayer now I'm not mentioning
these numbers just to brag about how
popular Demon Slayer is I am mentioning
these numbers because shuisha the
publisher of Demon Slayer will be
extremely motivated to continue the
manga in some way because there is just
so much money to be made here even if
kotoke fully intended to end the manga
completely in 2020 the explosion in
popularity and profitability of the
demon sire franchise changes the game
the publisher will definitely try to get
gotorege to continue Demon Slayer either
with a sequel a prequel or a spin-off
that takes place in the same world and
even if godogue doesn't want to continue
the story herself there is always the
option of having another manga take over
as was the case with Dragon Ball super
and boruto knowing how this industry
works I would be more surprised if there
wasn't some sort of continuation to the
story than if there was I mean it is
possible for kotoke to just say no I
don't need any more money and I don't
want to continue the story in any way
but that just doesn't seem like a likely
scenario I mean Kishimoto didn't really
need any more money either and yet
boruto still happened in fact Demon
Slayer has already released some extra
chapters that were created by authors
other than gotoke for instance the
rangoku and giyu Gaiden chapters were
written and illustrated by another
mangaka called hirano ryoji but if there
is a continuation to the story what kind
of continuation would it be there are
multiple options including a prequel
series that takes place during yorichi's
lifetime if this prequel happened it
would feature a pretty amazing cast
including yorichi kokushibo Tamayo muzan
then of course tanjiro's ancestor
sumioshi because of this I think that if
a prequel ever happens this is the most
likely period that it would be set in we
could also get a spin-off which takes
place in the same world but focuses on
other characters while potentially
featuring occasional appearances by
characters from the original so this
would mean new Heroes new demon villains
and new settings to explore either other
parts of Japan or maybe even other
countries the good thing about a
potential spin-off is that this would
allow for almost complete freedom to
whoever is writing it since that person
doesn't need to directly impact the main
story that said a spin-off that doesn't
focus on the characters that we know and
love could end up being a lot less
popular and thus less profitable the
final option is a sequel which would
either take place in the modern world
after the time skip or during the time
skip itself if the sequel were to take
place in the modern world then it would
focus on The Descendants and
reincarnations of the original
characters
featuring of course yushiro and the cat
but if the sequel were to take place
during the time skip so sometime after
the defeat of muzan and before the
modern era then theoretically we could
have the main characters that we know
and love be the focus of the story
although they would be somewhat older
this latter option allows us to see how
strong characters like inosuke zenitsu
and tanjiro could become as adults and
it would also allow us to witness the
rise of a new generation of hashira but
again this scenario would clearly have
to account for the fact that gotoke
wasn't planning on continuing the story
of tanjiro and the Gang for one thing as
I said earlier the Demon's air core was
disbanded because it was no longer
necessary after muzan's defeat in order
for the Demon's air core to be formed
once again a new demon threat would have
to emerge since yushiro survived all the
way up to the modern era we know that
muzan's death did not automatically kill
off every other demon so technically it
is possible that there are more demons
hiding out there somewhere and because
we now know that the blue Spider Lily
does still exist it is also possible
that new demons could be created in the
same way that demon muzan was himself
created one thousand years ago that said
there would need to be a good
justification for why this major new
demon threat was never mentioned in the
original story is this an ancient demon
who was turned by muzon hundreds of
years ago and maybe had a falling out
with muzon at some point in the past did
this demon maybe flee to another country
to escape muzan's wrath but then decide
to return after muzan's death I do think
that there's a way to make this work but
it has to be handled with care another
thing that a potential sequel featuring
the original characters would have to
account for are tanjiro's pretty severe
and debilitating injuries as a result of
his fight with muzan tanjiro lost the
use of one arm and one eye which is the
same type of injury that led tang and
Uzi to retire from being a hashira
because he didn't think that he could
fight effectively with such injuries so
if tanjiro is to become a hashira the
son hashira who uses hinokami kagura
then he has to find a way to fight
despite his injuries tanjiro is
extremely determined so I'm sure that
there is a way to make this work but it
certainly won't be easy other than just
training really hard in order to learn
to fight with only one hand and one eye
another option could be to have nezuko
fighting alongside him so for example
nezuku and tanjiro could decide to start
training together for years until they
learn to overcome each other's
shortcomings in battle and so then the
two of them together could become the
son hashira kind of like daki and yutaro
together were upper Moon six I mean
Demon Slayer is full of these types of
deliberate parallels between the heroes
and villains so I could definitely see
it happening however there could also be
more like cheat code ways of healing
tanjiro for example yushiro could use
tamayo's research to come up with a cure
for tanjiro's injuries or maybe some of
muzon cells within tanjiro could
reactivate and regenerate his body at
some point in the future in chapter 203
when tanjiro breaks free of muzan's grip
and wakes up we don't actually see muzon
cells disintegrate muzan just screams at
tanjiro not to leave him there but we
don't see his cells melting or
disappearing or anything like that so
who knows but again while it is possible
to make tanjiro the Sun hashira as part
of a potential sequel it would have to
be handled with care okay so let's
assume that all of this happens a new
demon threat appears years after the
defeat of muzon and the demon Slayers
are reassembled let's say that tanjiro
is now capable of fighting again and
that the hashira ranks are also being
re-established tanjiro or tanjiro and
nezuko together are given the title of
but who would the other hashira be in
this new Demon Slayer organization we
could expect guiyu and sonami to stay on
as the water and wind hashira provided
at the curse of the Demon Slayer Mark
doesn't kill them by age 25. since the
ubayashiki curse was clearly broken
after muzan's death and since yorichi
was able to live into his 80s we can
assume that it is indeed possible to
break the curse of the Demon Slayer Mark
and if all else fails you should all
just make some magical potion or
something and we're good zenitude then
becomes the Thunder hashira inosuke
becomes the Beast hashirath kanal
becomes the flower hashira and since
this is taking place years after the
defeat of muzon are now older senjuro
can succeed his brother as the flame
hashira that makes seven hashira and I
don't think that we necessarily need
nine hashira but if we wanted to fill
the other two positions maybe two new
characters could fill fill those spots
alternatively we could have older and
stronger versions of established
characters like kiria aoi or murata take
the spot and if you need to ask yes
murata would of course be the goat
hashira because he is the goat so to
reiterate I think that some sort of
Demon Slayer story continuation is
extremely likely because the series is
just so incredibly profitable the only
questions are what form this
continuation would take and how involved
the original mangakagotolege would
actually be the continuation could be a
prequel a spin-off or a sequel and all
of them could be really good if they are
handled the right way and if some
serious thought is put into the plot and
character development definitely let me
know down in the comments if you want to
see the Demon Slayer story continue in
some way and if so what type of
continuation do you want to see most
prequels spin-off sequel during in the
time skip sequels set in modern times
also who do you think would be the next
generation of hashira if the Demon's air
core were to be re-established after the
defeat of muzan don't forget to leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and I
hope that I was able to clearly and
effectively explain the time Skip and
all that stuff about descendants and
reincarnations don't forget to leave a
quick like it only takes a second but it
helps a lot and of course if you're new
here or maybe you watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
offroar don't forget to check out
itaikuji and use the promo code anime
Pro 500 link down below as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time time see ya Space Cowboys